hello everyone and welcome to a game
that will take very little of your time
to actually uh check out all the moves
but will keep you smiling for the rest
of the day it happened yesterday in the
french championship that started it's
round one and it's matthew corney versus
sebastian fella they are of similar
rating 25 51 25 52 they are both
grandmasters and this is a classical
game so this is what makes the game
incredible uh the game is very very
short and very reminiscent of the of a
certain game that was played in 1931 in
a simultaneous exhibition held by
alexander alejan he played against uh
his opponent vasich in banya luka and
we've checked out that game if you
haven't seen it it will be the first
link in the description below uh like i
said that definitely reminds of of this
game but it is incredible that something
like this can happen today in 2022
between two grand masters in a official
french championship so let's dive
straight into it uh uh cornet opens with
d4 we have d5 uh by fella uh c4 uh the
queen's gambit is on the board and the
e6 the gambit is declined with knight to
c3 knight to f6 and now c captures on d5
we have e captures on d5 and bishop to
g5 so the exchange uh variation is on
the board we have c6 strengthening the
d5 pawn and now pawn to e3 and now uh
here mostly bishop to f5 and bishop to
e7 are played those are the go to move
sometimes maybe h6 maybe knight b to d7
queen to b6 the move that was played in
the game is a bit rarer but still played
quite a lot it goes after the b2 pawn
and white of course has to defend it so
queen to c2 and now a wonderful pawn
sacrifice knights to e4 it's a temporary
pawn sacrifice black will regain the
pawn
but will also grab a very rapid
development so white accepts the
challenge uh knight captures an e4 pawn
captures queen captures this comes with
check and bishop to e6 now this is the
only move for black all the other moves
lose the game on the spot and now there
are a couple of games in the database
where castles was played but here we
have knight to f3 and it is now as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game uh white has to continue
development
may be coming to c4 as the light square
bishop on e6 is pinned you want to
castle and of course um
if black accepts the challenge regains
the pawn then rogue b1 gains us further
development and this is exactly how the
game uh continues queen captures on b2
we have rook to b1 attacking the queen
and queen to c3 check and now while you
could block this with the knight
allowing bishop to b4 then black is
attacking you are
yeah it's just not
in the spirit of the position why just
place king to d1 and now
this is no longer a chess game this is
now a bar fight and anything goes here
as you'll see in the game so knights the
d7 continuing development even offering
the b7 pawn but if you capture that the
knight to b6 the rook might be a little
bit stranded so it's not all that
spectacular we would probably see a very
very quick draw here and the game would
probably never be shown anywhere however
uh here bishop to d3 was played
i would like to mention rook to c1 uh
kicking away the queen with the idea of
bishop to c4 putting pressure on the
light square bishop uh is probably the
most objectively clean way to play this
but uh who amongst us could resist
playing bishop to d3 it's such a uh it's
such a classy movie
i imagine when when it was played
matthew really put the the absolute
biggest poker face uh he could master uh
you know on his face uh and uh
he was just hoping that uh his opponent
uh plays something weird and that's
exactly what happened in this game here
you could just continue knight b6 uh and
the game uh goes on maybe king e2 we
artificially castle it's a nice game for
both white and black but in the game
pawn the h6 was played and now uh well
if you've seen the game alejand versus
vasi you guys know what i'm talking
about but if you haven't and if you are
maybe new to chess and in the to the
channel in general
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute stunning
crushing idea for white while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
brilliant queen sacrifice and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is queen captures on e6 that's that's
the good stuff yes this happened in a
classical game in 2022 between two
grandmasters in a official french
championship we can even do it in slow
motion as this move deserves it if any
move deserves it queen captures an e6 uh
the only move for black is either bishop
to e7 which ends in queen captures
checkmate and of course if the queen
sacrifice is accepted then the other
bishop delivers checkmate bishop the g6
checkmate
and that's it no more moves uh move 15
black gets checkmated and this is uh
well up until today i thought it was
unimaginable that something like this
could happen but it did uh it's a
similar i think in the alien game also
bishop to g6 ended the game only the
dark square bishop was an a3 slicing
over this diagonal which was
which is kind of more aesthetically
pleasing but i mean i i'm pretty sure no
one no one is complaining uh
this one truly spectacular and big
congratulations to matthew corney for
for pulling off this one i imagine he's
already quite a celebrity now uh as i
mean this is unimaginable
uh so yeah uh that's the game i hope you
guys uh enjoyed it uh i would also like
to thank uh connecting benoit for for
suggesting it to me i would probably see
it as uh
all the big chess sites already
published it but it's always uh i i
always enjoy it when you guys uh suggest
me such gems uh uh for everyone else to
enjoy as well uh but yeah and that's the
game really hope you guys enjoyed it and
that it will keep you happy for the rest
of the day uh i would like to thank
kathleen altia cashman robert arthur
cold feet reckless spawn and ravishing
reptiles youtube for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and another
certain game uh
between stockfish and chess master is
coming up today so thank y'all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day